[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
engagieren sie sich für die flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine haben vielleicht sogar
jemanden bei sich aufgenommen oder sind
sie aktiv in der klimabewegung oder
sammeln regelmäßig unterschriften oder
finden sie hier aktivismus keeper zu oft
im unnützen aktionismus heute fragen wir
wie wir etwas bewegen können und
beleuchten blinde flecken in unserem
engagement zu gast in zwei experten zu
diesen fragen vor raul krauthausen
er ist moderator autor und inklusions
aktivist seine arbeit wurde mehrfach
ausgezeichnet unter anderem trägt er das
bundesverdienstkreuz
und zu gast ist bei uns stefan rieder er
ist philosoph und lehrt und arbeitet am
ethik zentrum der universität zürich
ganz herzlich willkommen herzlichen dank
für die einladung
ja herr krauthausen viele leute fragen
sich zurzeit muss ich mich engagieren in
dieser situation mit dem krieg in der
ukraine flüchtlinge bei mir aufnehmen
geldspenden oder vielleicht deutsch
kurse anbieten wie sehen sie das also
ich würde jetzt uni dem zwang draus
machen ja die fragezeichen habe ich
dafür die ressourcen die kapazitäten
sowohl mental als auch vielleicht
finanziell als auch zeitlich
so dass sich da jetzt keinen imperativ
draus machen würde aber ich denke jetzt
ist jetzt alex reid sich die frage zu
stellen was kann ich geben was was kann
ich tun und daneben auch zu gucken aber
es kann auch als kleines sein das muss
jetzt nicht gleich die große helden trat
sein wo gibt es netzwerke wo ich mich
beteiligen kann und ich würde eher dazu
raten inzwischen er mich in ruhe
anzuschließen als jetzt noch eine aktion
zu starten
in einem interview mit dem tages
anzeiger kürzlich gesagt eine
spezifische pflicht flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen die gebe es tatsächlich
nicht das heißt ich kann nicht beruhigt
zurücklehnen wenn ich meine wohnung
jetzt nicht zu teilen anbiete so würde
ich das nicht formulieren ich glaube
tatsächlich werden als privatpersonen
mindestens jetzt nicht die pflicht uns
spezifisch für die menschen aus der
ukraine einzusetzen der ukraine krieg
ist ja nur ein problem ganz ganz vielen
wir können uns nicht überall engagieren
und haben daher auch bis zu einem
gewissen grad glaube ich die freiheit zu
entscheiden wo wir etwas tun
ich glaube aber schon die allermeisten
von uns haben grundsätzlich eine pflicht
irgendeine art des engagements zu leben
das hat verschiedene gründe das hat zum
beispiel glaube ich mit fairness zu tun
also stellen wir uns eine welt vor wo
niemand sich engagiert es wäre eine
schreckliche welt eine welt in der es
keine sportvereine gäbe keine quartiers
feste zu wenig
küchen für die obdachlosen zu wenig
aufnahme stellen für geflüchtete das
heißt wir profitieren alle enorm davon
dass andere menschen sich engagieren und
ich glaube es wäre falsch ein leben lang
davon zu profitieren ohne irgendwann in
irgendeiner form auch seinen teil zu
diesem gemeinsamen
das wäre eben auf eine weise unfair aber
einen 200 ausmachen wollen sie beide
nicht also ich denke es gibt eigentlich
für so wenn es in den ländern in denen
wir leben für sowas eigentlich klare
verantwortlichkeiten und lage strukturen
für menschen die hilfe suchen es gibt so
was wie
regeln und gesetze und auch jetzt als
wächter für geflüchtete menschen
tragisch ist einfach nur dass sie oft
wie eingehalten oder ignoriert werden
oder eben plötzlich alle überrascht sind
dass menschen in bahnhöfen plötzlich
ankommen und hilfe brauchen obwohl das
alles vorhersehbar war es gibt irgendwie
zumindest in deutschland habe ich
manchmal den eindruck so die mentalität
von den verantwortlichen das weggucken
und das bloß nicht wahrhaben wollen und
dann sind sie alle entsetzt und
schockiert und dann muss die
zivilgesellschaft einspringen um diesen
pfaden der dann vor ort wirklich
entsteht also menschlicher schaden der
da vor ort entsteht dann irgendwie zu
lösen und das bis heute geflüchtete mit
behinderung im bahnhof übernachten
müssen weil es nicht genug
barrierefreien wohnraum gibt ist jetzt
auch keine überraschende erkenntnis
sondern es ist einfach werden
2015 wissen wir dass das man ist aber
nicht so richtig verstehen würden sie
sagen in einem perfekten sozialstaat
bräuchte es sozusagen gar nicht
engagement oder aktivismus gleichzeitig
gibt es ja ganz viele dinge die der
staat selbstverständlich nie bereit
stellen jetzt haben quartier fest
erwähnt dass lebt natürlich vom
engagement
es gibt auch studien von benevol schweiz
der dachorganisation für
freiwilligenarbeit in der schweiz die
sagt vier von zehn schweizerinnen und
schweizer engagieren sich regelmäßig und
da runterfahren natürlich auch solche
dinge wie aktuell seien im lokalen
fußball verband oder nachbarschaftshilfe
unbedingt dass ich glaube wir müssen
unterscheiden es gibt glaube ich gingen
die wollen von denen wollen wir nicht
dass der staat sie uns zur verfügung
steht stellt von denen es vielleicht
auch gar nicht möglich bei denen es gar
nicht möglich dass der staat sie zur
verfügung stellt und da ist dann umso
mehr das engagement von privatpersonen
gefragt bei anderen dingen ist es eben
so dass wir denken die erste
verantwortlichkeit würde eigentlich auf
den staat fallen und wir werden dann
vielleicht umso mehr gefragt oder erst
gefragt wenn der staat mit seiner
verantwortung nicht nachkommen kann wir
dürfen auch nicht verkennen also ich bin
jetzt nicht so oft in der schweiz aber
die autos sind hier schon luxuriöser und
größer als die in berlin
der wohlstand ist ja auch irgendwie an
von jemand anderem geld der
kanalarbeiten erwirtschaftet wurde der
richtung viel wohlstand oder die und der
lieben weiß ich heute dass es so dass
der wohnraum sich in den letzten 50
jahren pro bundesbürger verdoppelt hat
und wenn man jetzt rein mathematisch die
leute dazu bringen könnte dass jeder
quadratmeter seiner wohnfläche abgabe
gab es genug wohnraum für alle so aber
das geht natürlich nur mathematisch
stadt gerettet praktisch aber es ist
schon interessant dass wir uns auch in
unserem wohlstand gewöhnt haben und
jetzt davon auch nicht mehr soviel
bereits und abzugeben ich verstehe ich
warum autos immer größer werden aber
trotzdem nicht mehr platz und auto ist
gut das ist noch mal eine andere frage
die es auch interessant auch wenn hier
noch einmal zurückgehen zu dieser frage
was muss ich denn eigentlich tun es gibt
ja viele die würden sagen naja ich
bezahle ja schon steuern ist auch ein
beitrag für die allgemeinheit und ich
versuche zb mich vegetarisch zu ernähren
oder ich setze mich eben wie ein keine
ahnung für fairtrade-produkte das reicht
doch ein schon ich glaube wir sollten
vielleicht mal klären was bedeutet
engagement überhaupt engagement ist grob
gesagt der positive einsatz für eine
wertvolle sache die über die eigene
person hinaus geht also die sache für
die ich mich einsetzen muss wertvoll
sein wir würden nicht sagen die nazis
haben sich sehr für den holocaust
engagiert zum beispiel der wert muss
über meine eigene person hinaus gehen
also wenn ich zwei wochen am strand die
sonne genießen dann ist das vielleicht
schön und wertvoll ab wir werden nicht
sagen ich habe mich jetzt sehr für mich
selber engagiert im normalfall und das
ist jetzt der entscheidende punkt für
die frage diese stellen unser einsatz
für diese sache muss positiv sein also
ich habe mich noch nicht schon dadurch
zum beispiel für die obdachlosen in
zürich eingesetzt dass ich diesen
menschen nicht schade dass ich sie nicht
töten nicht verletzte nicht bestehen
und ich glaube manche von diesen dingen
die sie erwähnt haben zb eben unseren
konsum von tierprodukten zu reduzieren
will ich deshalb gar nicht so sehr als
als engagement bezeichnen wollen also
die tierindustrie zb gibt ausnahmen da
der größte teil beruht auf
unrechtmäßigen töten und zufügung von
leid ich glaube wenn wir die produkte
konsumieren machen wir uns zu einem
gewissen teil zu komplizinnen von diesem
töten von diesem unrecht und das heißt
wenn wir jetzt unseren konsum von
tierprodukten reduzieren ist das erstmal
ein unterlassen von einem ungerechten
unterlassen einer schädigung noch gar
nicht ein positives engagement deswegen
ich will das nicht kleinreden ich glaube
es braucht viele opfer es ist nicht
leicht diesen konsum zu reduzieren
aber es ist wichtig dass wieder das tun
umso wichtiger dass wir hier anfangen
aber ich glaube schon wir werden dann
auch in der verantwortung nicht
unbedingt hier stehen zu bleiben sondern
noch einen schritt weiter ins positive
engagement zu gehen ich würde auch gerne
noch ergänzt es wird jetzt mal endlich
ganz oft gesagt eben jeder muss auf
seine co2 fußabdruck achten und
irgendwie sollen alle auf plastik
strohhalme verzichten und keine ahnung
ist und dass es das wert so ein bisschen
die legende dass wir durch unseren
anderen konsum die welt retten können
aber ich glaube die wirklichen probleme
dieser welt werden gar nicht durch
plastik strohhalme und/oder
die bambus zahnbürste gelöst werden
sondern einfach durch keine ahnung
riesige kreuzfahrtschiffe die die umwelt
verpesten und zerstört und die mehrere
kaputtmachen durch konzerne gegen den
massenweisen zukauf von von lng das
jetzt in deutschland aus anderen ländern
aber bloß nicht aus muss etwas negativ
hat sich einer der letzten zwei monaten
so krass geändert von wir müssen aus dem
gas aussteigen hinzu wir müssen viel
mehr gas woanders her bekommen aber das
problem bleibt nach wie vor gas völlig
egal vergeben und wir müssen eigentlich
dafür sorgen dass wir die umwelt in
großem maßstab retten und das wird nicht
geändert werden dadurch dass ich eine
bambus dran würste im drogeriemarkt
gekauft das ist jetzt auch schon wieder
die frage was hilft eigentlich da wollen
wir später auch noch drüber sprechen
hier passiert ist das spannende dass die
politik sich auch gerne zurücklehnen und
die verantwortung an die bürger innen
abgibt und sagt na ja er ist aber auch
mit eurem konsum drauf an aber der
bürger die bürgerin war wie das problem
ernsthaft um den punkt den sie gemacht
haben war ja noch stärker auch diese
unterscheidungen ich sie richtig
verstanden habe engagement heißt
sozusagen nicht einfach nicht zu tun was
schädlich ist sondern im positiven sinn
etwas zu bewegen also eben andere nicht
zu bestehen ist kein engagement sondern
sich einfach sich anständig verhalten
und darunter würden sie auch keine tier
produkte konsumieren jetzt zählen da
kann er wahrscheinlich lange darüber
sprechen ich würde gerne noch eine
andere unterscheidung von ihnen
aufnehmen sie haben ja dieses buch
geschrieben wie kann ich was bewegen die
kraft des konstruktiven aktivismus
gemeinsam mit benjamin schwarz und in
diesem buch geht es um aktivismus was
ist denn die differenz zwischen
engagement und aktivismus für sie also
gar keine ich würde so ungefähr so
beschreiben wir wieder auch also dass
aktivismus schon wie von von einer
handlung überzeugt ist jemand die welt
zu einem besseren ort zu machen und
einen ganz klaren missstand zu
beseitigen und oder zu bekämpfen
und das sehr touristisch also bis zu
also dass der aktivist die aktivistin
das teilweise soweit tut dass es
bis zum burnout kommen kann ja und dass
der oder die aktivisten auch nicht die
erwartung habe davon leben zu können
dann wäre der oder sie nämlich lobbyist
und würde dafür geld bekommen von der
branche keine ahnung es gibt ja auch
lobbyisten für die gute sache und die
wird dann aber von verbänden bezahlt
werden aber viele aktivistinnen
engagieren sich ehrenamtlich und tun das
wirklich bis zur selbstaufgabe und das
geht schon über engagement hinaus
irgendwie mal bei einem sportverein
geholfen zu haben und kuchen gebacken zu
haben das ist dann wirklich auch lange
organisiert netzwerke aufbauen kann sich
auch mit politiker innen streiten und
daneben auch die ganze hänge
einzukassieren von allen seiten bis hin
zu neid missgunst eifersucht oder
einfach aus sie haben gesagt es muss ein
missstand beseitigt werden das ist für
engagement nicht und mit dem zwingend
oder wenn man ein dorffest sich
engagiert für ein dorffest weil ihm ein
missstand bar das heißt aktivismus wäre
diesbezüglich anders definiert ich würde
auch sagen so ein bisschen enger
engagement ist nicht schon per se
politische ziele haben also ich kann
mich eben
quartiers vereinen engagieren oder ich
kann mich auch einfach ganz privat und
klammheimlich für den wiedehopf in
meiner region engagieren indem ich zum
beispiel die nisthilfen aufstelle das
ist noch nicht aktivismus aktivismus
höchstens dann wenn ich eben auf die
straße gehen auf die barrikaden gehe und
für strengere umweltgesetze zum beispiel
protestierer also aktivismus ist
diejenige form von von engagement jeden
ganz genuin politische ziele verfolgt
und könnte man nicht sagen ihr
engagement für den wiedehopf wird dann
zum aktivismus wenn wir feststellen auf
der linie hat zb ein religiöses symbol
ist für eine minderheit die diesen
wieder holz ganz dringend brauchen um
ihre kultur
weiterleben zu können oder dann wird es
zu einer aktivistischen praxen und dann
vielleicht die leute sagen wir mal auch
zur rede stellen die dagegen sind
da haben sich auch mit diesen menschen
anlegen und dann gleich auch umgekehrt
werden also actebis muss geht schon auch
oft an die grenze des radikalen und da
bin ich nicht ganz einer meinung mit
benjamin schwarz in den vororten ich
würde sogar sagen ins radikale rein
und ich finde es sogar sehr interessant
in diesem diskurs dass viele
aktivistinnen in deutschland von
vorneherein
radikalität ausschließen und sagen ja
das muss auf jeden fall gewaltfrei sein
und auf jeden fall da der phoenix dinge
kaputt machen aber ich glaube damit lee
mitglied sich auch aktivismus schon
wieder von anfang an ohne zu wissen ob
es nicht vielleicht das irgendwann nötig
wäre sich zu wehren weil sonst gewinnen
immer die anderen und ein nazi
der hat vor gewalt scheinbar keine
werbung und wenn wir die ganze hätte man
sagen wir müssten gewaltfrei sein ohne
uns wären zu dürfen
kann das auch das ist natürlich noch mal
eine schwierige frage und ich möchte
auch gerne darauf hinweisen dass die
ganze diskussion um zivilen ungehorsam
und die frage der gewaltlosigkeit die
haben hier an diesem tisch schon einmal
diskutiert mit robin zertifikates einem
philosophen aus berlin der sich
spezifisch mit dieser frage auseinander
setzt also diese frage oder dieses
gespräch sozusagen kann man auch noch
einmal nachschauen aber ich würde gerne
jetzt noch mehr auch vertiefen warum wir
uns eigentlich engagieren und warum wir
eben zu aktivisten werden sie haben eine
gesprächsreihe herr kraut 1000 hs face
to face und da haben sie kürzlich katrin
beetle zu gast eine künstlerin und da
sagen sie es hat mich sehr beeindruckt
weil menschen mit behinderung permanent
gegen barrieren ankämpfen müssen haben
wir gar keine wahl nicht aktives gingen
zu sein das ist wahr und das finde ich
auch so vermessen manchmal das dann von
nicht betroffenen oft gesagt mit ja wenn
du den missstand ofin es dann engagiert
ich doch weil menschen mit behinderung
engagieren sich permanent also alleine
ich hier herzukommen jetzt eigentlich
schon vier stunden aktivismus gewesen
weil ich mich mit dem berliner
fotografen gestritten habe weil die sich
geweigert hatte einen elektrischen
rollstuhl mitzunehmen und das obwohl ich
alles nach deren vorgaben richtig
gemacht habe und dass letztendlich
dieses engagement vier stunden
seinerzeit niemand anderes ohne
behinderung investieren muss überhaupt
nicht gewerkschaft wird vom system um
das gleiche zu erreichen wie herrieden
nämlich hier im studio zu sein das wird
total oft übersehen und darin liegt auch
eine riesige burnout gefahr weil gerade
aktivisten denn die sich für etwas
engagieren von dem sie es oder gegen
etwas engagieren von dem sie selber
betroffen sind natürlich auch nie
feierabend machen können ich war vor
drei monaten mit ein paar anderen
rollstuhl kolleginnen im urlaub und er
sind nach usedom gefahren und das sollte
ein barrierefreier urlaub sport sein und
dann kommen wieder an und nichts war
barrierefrei außer das hotel also castro
oder strand nicht und so weiter und so
fort und dann machen also aktivistinnen
die eigentlich urlaub machen wollen in
ihrem urlaub wieder aktivismus weil wir
uns dann im rathaus beschwert haben und
dann einfach da das rathaus besetzt
haben und zu sagen das geht ich glaube
10.000 euro für alle zusammen für eine
woche investiert und wir wollten
eigentlich urlaub machen um das produkt
nicht bekommen das wir bestellt haben
interessant in ihrem buch macht ja
carola rakete die die aktivisten eine
ähnliche aussage uns war gewissermaßen
über uns als als menschheit insgesamt
wir haben drei haben die seenotretter
oder auch unter aus seenot retten ist
sie sehr sehr bekannt geworden macht
aber auch im bereich ökologie und
aktivismus ganz genau sie hat auch
gesagt wir haben als menschheit jetzt
gar nicht mehr die wahl ob wir uns
engagieren oder nicht und ich glaube da
ist etwas dran also wenn wir jetzt nicht
die kursrichtung verändern wenn wir
nicht in irgendeiner weise im großen
wandel vollziehen dann werden eben aus
der krise in die katastrophe schlittern
und insofern gilt vielleicht sagen
dieses bild für uns als als menschheit
insgesamt sind das jetzt nicht mehr die
wahl hatten das feld dann auch auf alle
individuen unglaublich zurück also diese
verantwortung die sich daraus ergibt für
die menschheit als ganze bedeutet dann
eben auch eine verantwortung für
einzelne institutionen einzelne staaten
aber auch für die privatpersonen eben
den eigenen teil dazu beizutragen aber
das wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen sie
sind ein weißer zizmann wenn ich das mal
so sagen darf das heißt sie haben keine
primäre diskriminierung sexismus zum
beispiel dürfte selten seien bei ihnen
rassismus wahrscheinlich auch sie haben
keine zumindest sichtbare behinderung
und damit einher geht dann vielleicht
die frage wofür soll ich mich denn
eigentlich engagieren weil bayern
krauthausen sie engagieren sich ja für
ganz viele dinge im übrigen aber wie sie
sagen wenn ich in urlaub fahren sind sie
eigentlich immer schon aktivist schließt
das für sie
ich glaube
auch für menschen wie mich jetzt nicht
so direkt von einer form von
diskriminierung betroffen sind gibt es
dann dinge die uns erst mal persönlich
irgendwie bewegen irgendwelche formen
von unrecht irgendwelche probleme die
uns persönlich
betroffen machen und ich glaube es ist
gut mal damit anzufangen also mit dieser
eigenen betroffenheit dem gefühl von
solidarität da den ersten schritt zu
machen ich glaube dann allerdings ist es
aber auch wichtig
immer wieder ein schritt zurück zu
machen mir zu überlegen gibt es nicht
noch andere probleme die mich auch
betreffen könnten oder betroffen machen
könnten gibt es nicht noch andere form
von engagement bei problemen die
vielleicht vernachlässigte sind die
vielleicht größer sind wo ich vielleicht
noch effektiver was bewirken könnte um
dann eben zu einem engagement zu finden
was letztlich besonders effektiv ist und
das würde ich sagen jetzt auf jeden fall
ein kriterium wenn sie fragen wo soll
ich mich engagieren erstmal da wo ich
besonders viel bewirken kann wobei das
ja auch eine schwierigkeit ist dass er
sie fühlen sich ja verbunden der
bewegung des so genannten effektiven
altruismus sie spenden selber sehr viel
und die der effektive auf tourismus der
fragt ja auch eben wo kann ich die
spendengelder zum beispiel möglichst
effektiv einsetzen und wenn man an die
empfehlungen auf dieser website liest
dann kommt man beispiel auf malaria
prävention in afrikanischen ländern oder
auch entwurmung spuren von kindern damit
die den schulbesuchen auch wirklich
machen können das sind natürlich dann
nicht solche dinge wie speisekarten in
blindenschrift zu drucken oder für
rampen im quartier sich einzusetzen also
ist dieses dieser blick nicht sozusagen
auch ein problem sieht man denn den
blick der effektiven touristin ja weil
natürlich im grunde genommen die
anliegen für die sie sich jetzt vor
allem einsetzen dann zu kurz kommen auf
jeden fall also es wäre fatal wenn wir
jetzt alle nur noch geld spenden würden
für malaria netze und entwurmung ich
glaube eine bemühungen des effektiven
altruismus ist sozusagen
etwas zu korrigieren eine art korrektiv
darzustellen weil der verdacht ist dass
wir eben oft als zu unkritisch uns
einfach nur dort engagieren wo wir
gerade ein problem sehen wo wir
vielleicht einfach selber nur von einem
problem betroffen sind wir machen eben
nicht diesen schritt zurück um zu
überlegen gibt es nicht anderswo noch
größere probleme die genauso real sind
vielleicht nicht vor den eigenen augen
aber wo wir eben am ende umso mehr
bewirken kann ich glaube nicht dass
diese dieses kriterium der effektivität
wo kann ich am meisten bewirken dass das
das einzige ist also unbedingt das ist
auch wichtig haben wir eine persönliche
beziehung zu ein problem gibt vielleicht
leute die schon in der verantwortung
eigentlich wären das andere problem zu
lösen und so weiter aber ich glaube es
ist eben doch ein kriterium was wir
wichtiger nehmen könnten und sollten
also dass ich einen ganz wichtigen punkt
also einmal ich bin ja auch weiß dass
man ab zwar eine behinderung aber es
gibt auch andere kategorien in denen ich
nicht diskriminiert werde und das heißt
es ist jetzt auch in meiner
verantwortung unserer verantwortung
natürlich den menschen die davon
betroffen sind die bühnen zu geben wenn
wir in der lage sind sie zu betreten die
anderen nicht in der lage wären sie zu
bekommen das heißt es ist auch in meiner
verantwortung genauso platz zu machen
als alliierte an der seite zu stehen und
auch ich mache immer noch in der
kategorie in der hinsicht viele fehler
haben natürlich es ist ja auch so
ehrlich müssen wir auch sein
aktivismus oder wahrscheinlich auch in
akademie tut es eigentlich auch gut wenn
man gehört wird wenn man eingeladen und
so weiter macht ja auch was mit den
eigenen ego aber das eben hinten
anzustellen und manche gucken okay wäre
eigentlich wenn der ehrlich zu uns
selbst sind der bessere ansprechpartner
in zu diesem thema und deswegen habe ich
dieses buch auch nur schreiben können
wir mit den wahren aktivistinnen die
noch viel größer in den medien sichtbar
waren hat sich es vielleicht war zu
diesem thema zu sprechen und auch
selbstkritisch mit den sachen sich
auseinanderzusetzen und
auch sehr spannend was reden gesagt hat
dieses effektiver altruismus das kann
man sicherlich auch in deutschland sich
überlegen oder in der schweiz
das macht glaube ich mehr sinn geld wenn
man sich für die belange behinderter
menschen
engagieren möchte geld er den
organisationen zu spenden die von
behinderten menschen geführt werden auch
dass es wesentlich effektiver als wenn
wir das pro infirmis geben wo
wahrscheinlich ausschließlich nicht in
der die menschen in führungsetagen die
projekte definieren entscheiden und
sagen wohin welche fördergelder gehen
sollen das heißt es gibt ja
organisationen wie tatkraft zum beispiel
vom islam alisa der hier auch in der
schweizer sehr sehr bekanntes in dem
bereich und da wahrscheinlich als selbst
betroffener ja viel besser einschätzen
kann wenn wir schon rampen als 70
organisationen der zivilgesellschaft
finanzieren müssen dann zu entscheiden
wo also vielleicht ist eine eine disco
hoch eine angesagte des kunden in zürich
wesentlich effektivere spende mit der
rampe ausgestattet als die nächste
apotheke deren eigentlichen
fahrtrichtung es wäre von sich aus
barrierefrei zu sein das ist ja auch
eine schwierigkeit oder dass man als
aktivistin oder aktivist sozusagen
aufgaben erledigt die das stadtleben
über absolute oder eine private
institution mich beschäftigt immer noch
diese frage was eigentlich tun was man
ja schon sehen muss es gibt zig
aktivisten aktivisten es gibt
unglaublich viele bewegungen und es gibt
diese idee von karl popper der mal
gesagt hat es gibt eigentlich gar keinen
richtigen
aktivistin aktivismus sehr kritisch dass
es gibt immer in so einen aktionismus in
dem es eigentlich darum geht ein
partikularinteressen zu verteidigen also
wenn man sich zum beispiel überlegt es
gibt die partikel kräftigen bewegung die
stricken und häkeln ganz viel und gegen
die mode muttis vorzugehen es gibt den
pfad aktivisten menschen die sich
einsetzen gegen die diskriminierung von
übergewichtigen menschen oder es gibt
den aktivisten eine bewegung die sich
einsetzt für die möglichkeit in der
öffentlichkeit zu stellen also jeden
sein partikularinteressen sage ich jetzt
mal und dann auch jeden seinen
aktivismus ich glaube dass die richtig
da richtige blick auf die welt ich
glaube das ist nicht das richtige bild
ich glaube das entspricht auch nicht der
realität sondern auf einer weise glaube
ich können wir auch sagen es gibt hier
jetzt eine große krise und was wir
brauchen ist einen großen wandel um dem
zu begegnen und all diese verschiedenen
probleme und aspekte hängen ja alle
zusammen also wenn wir erst zum beispiel
schaffen mehr inklusion zu leben mit
menschen mit behinderung dann kann man
das vielleicht allgemeinen gelegenen
offener zu werden gegenüber menschen die
anders sind als wir das wiederum kann
zum beispiel helfen gegen rassismus
vorzugehen wenn wir rassismus abgebaut
haben werden wir offene und
empfänglicher für katastrophen die sich
auf anderen kontinenten abspielen das
wiederum muss und sensibilisieren für
die klimakrise und die klimakrise
wiederum involviert auch tiere so dass
wir am ende war die tieren sind also ich
glaube das wäre vielleicht ein
fruchtbarer blick dass wir uns bemühen
nicht dass die verschiedenen formen des
aktivismus sich gegenseitig das wasser
abgraben und sich gegenseitig bekämpfen
sondern dass wir sehen letztlich
nicht um toleranz und gegenseitigen
respekt gehen wir vergrößern sollten gut
aber dann würde ich gerne nachfragen es
gab eine frage in den sozialen medien
die mir im vorfeld ganz oft gestellt
worden ist und ich muss an dieser stelle
auch mal sagen ich bin immer begeistert
über die vielen fragen die uns geschickt
werden und möchte mich ganz herzlich
bedanken bei unseren zuschauern und
zuschauen und oft wurde gefragt wo soll
ich denn anfangen weil diese frage
stellt sich dann natürlich ich kann mich
ja auch tausendfache art und weise
engagieren uhr beginnen herr krauthausen
also vielleicht nur kurze der frage
davor mit dem thema
aktivismus aktionismus ich habe dem
studium der gesellschafts und
wirtschaftskommunikation auf hinweg
gelernt du musst immer anschlussfähig
bleiben also was passiert eigentlich aus
diesem dritten mann ist ein kleiner
eigentliche botschaft und wie kannst du
diese ziele nachdem wir gestrickt hat
zum beispiel weiter erhalten oder welche
strukturen stecken eigentlich
hinterlegte wissen denn wenn man kann
ich sind männer diejenigen die ein
problem damit haben dass frauen in der
öffentlichkeit stellen das sind
wahrscheinlich nicht frauen haben die
probleme haben wenn mit sehr großer
wahrscheinlichkeit männer das heißt wir
müssen auch darüber nachdenken in
barcelona sebastian männerdominierten
gesellschaft leben wir eigentlich und
wie können wir damit auch umgehen müssen
männer in dem kontext einfach mal die
klappe halten wenn es darum geht dass
frauen gehen einmal die einzigen besen
sind die stellen können oder menschen
mit brüsten stellen können dass das
überhaupt funktionieren kann nur so und
wenn wir diese menschen diskriminieren
weil das liegt da geht wo sie es gerne
aber würden weil das irgendwelche
öffentliche ordnung stören könnte dann
ist das ganz klar diskriminierend und
das deb team auch in anderen bereichen
rassismus damit betonen sie eigentlich
diese vernetzung der problematik oder
wie das serien aber leider also so dass
oft männer dafür verantwortlich sind für
diese probleme weil sie seit
jahrhunderten diese gesellschaften
formen und dann sowas einfach auch nie
in deren eigentlich im leben passiert
oft haben männer gar keine care arbeit
gemacht und dann war das ein für die
einfach oft kein problem und das ist
glaube ich ganz wichtig und die aktuelle
umfrage die sie gestellt haben wo
anfangen wie engagieren das ist mir ganz
super individuelle frage also ich habe
am anfang für mich selber auch gesagt
naja gut für behinderte menschen kann
sich ja immer engagieren das ist ja
offensichtlich was immer vier räder
dabei besitzt dein leben lang im
rollstuhl
das ist sehr einfach und ich habe am
anfang nicht für andere dinge zu
engagieren
menschen die kein opfer haben in berlin
und so weiter und ich habe einfach
gemerkt dass fühlt sich das fühlt sich
die authentische ich hab selber wir auf
der straße gelebt das ist super anmaßen
das zu tun lassen sie doch eher den
menschen dabei helfen die mit diesen
menschen zusammenarbeit oder die das
selber organisieren und wir haben in
deutschland ein projekt gestartet das
nennt sich fantastisch helfen wo bürger
innen in supermärkten ihre pfandbons
spenden können für zum beispiel
bedürftige in dem fall die berliner
tafel und ich vielleicht ganz kurz
erklären weil sie das in der schweiz
nicht haben also das sind sozusagen die
bruins die man bekommt wenn und pfandgut
dazu flaschen mit von zurückgibt und man
kriegt dann sonne ab 25 cent pro flasche
ungefähr und diesem grund kann ich
spenden das war unsere annahme und wir
haben es dann mit der berliner tafel
gestartet und ich habe sehr viel mit der
chefin der berliner tafel über dieses
thema gesprochen und sie sagte auch was
sie sehr träge spendet ist eigentlich
dass sie größer die tafel wird desto
größer ist das eigentliche problem
das heißt diese skalieren diese idee
dass gemeinnützigkeit skalieren muss und
dann auf zu betriebswirtschaftlich
gedacht wird ist auch gleichzeitig ein
soziales problem und es ist passiert
inzwischen das in sozialämtern in berlin
den den menschen die grundsicherung
beantragen oder hartz 4 1 bei uns all
die 2 das den gesagt wird ja wenn sie
sich das essen nicht leisten können dann
gehen sie doch zur
tafel ist ein ort wo man entlang wo
sonst die bank finanziert das heißt hier
findet eine verantwortung die fusion
statt da gibt der stark verantwortung an
die private und zivilgesellschaft ab
ohne dafür zu sorgen dass menschen in
den von grundsicherung leben können
diesen missstand zu ändern indem sie
mehr grundsicherung das heißt eigentlich
kann aktivismus negative auswirkungen
haben denn sozusagen sozialstaatliche
aufgaben übernommen werden das einzige
was man da tun kann und dass er macht
die frau wird von der berliner tafel sie
nimmt kein geld vom staat sie sagt wir
zeigen nur jäger wir werden das problem
immer kürzer wird aber sobald wir haben
kein geld vom staat zu nehmen machen wir
uns dazu mit
peter iden und legitimieren dass das
dilemma was ich vorhin schon
angesprochen haben in dem sich manchmal
der aktivismus befindet also wenn wir
ein problem lösen was eigentlich in der
verantwortung eine institution also des
staates läge dann fühlt sich die
entsprechende institution von ihrer
verantwortung enthoben andererseits ist
es manchmal eben so wenn wir es nicht
tun da macht sieben gar niemand und dann
bleibt das problem ungelöst das ist ein
dilemma übrigens auch nicht nur im
privaten aktivismus sondern es ist auch
schon ganz ganz lange eine schwierigkeit
in der entwicklungszusammenarbeit wie es
darum geht das eben lokale regierung
dann sich von der verantwortung enthoben
fühlen wenn wir bestimmte probleme
angehen ich glaube aber man darf das
problem auch nicht
überdramatisieren also vielleicht ist
gerade auch nochmal frau rakete dass das
beste beispiel sie hat ja was ähnliches
getan nämlich eben sich eingesetzt für
geflüchtete auf mittelmeer erstmal eine
aufgabe übernommen die wahrscheinlich in
der verantwortung von institutionen
gewesen wäre damit aber gerade sozusagen
das öffentliche licht geworfen auf
dieses institutionelle versagen und und
und und das in den mittelpunkt gerückt
haben ich glaube
und das bemühen gibt es vielleicht auch
auswege aus diesem dilemma das
interessante bei frau ist viel
gesprochen waren dass das was sie getan
hat diese tat oder dieser diese diese
aktion dass sie menschen gerettet hat
und sich mit der italienischen
polizei angelegt hat und so weiter und
so fort sagt sie ist eigentlich das ist
kein wirklicher aktivismus gewesen weil
sie hat sich ein geltendes recht
gehalten und da ist es einfach mal so
dass das größere schiffe einfach immer
vorfahrt hat und wenn das polizeiboot
kleiner ist dann ist es in dem moment
egal das ist ein polizeiboot und das
sind dann noch einmal die die feinheiten
genau und daneben ziviler ungehorsam was
ist jetzt ungehorsam genossen ich wollte
eigentlich nur sagen dass sie auch am
ende juristisch fast immer gewonnen und
dann erzählt ihr auch dass wenn wir dann
von zwei des vorfilter gegen die als
radikalen zwischen der teilweise auch in
den medien gefeiert werden auch dass es
überhaupt liegt radikal was die freude
an bewegung fordert ist die einhaltung
der pariser klimaabkommen und gesetze
und vereinbarte regeln einzuhalten nur
konservativ das ist nicht aktivismus
und jetzt haben sie mir sozusagen den
übergang gemacht zum zunächst ein thema
quasi haben schon mehrere male jetzt
gesprochen vom aktivist burn out also
diesem phänomen dass aktivisten
aktivisten erschöpfen können an ihren
aufgaben
eine person die übrigens dieser begriff
stammt von meillerghp 1 muss man
vielleicht noch sagen 1994 eingeführt
eine psychologin und eine person die
offen darüber spricht ist merritt
schäfer eine junge klima aktivisten aus
bern die damit auch an die
öffentlichkeit gegangen ist dass sie
eben sehr viel sich einsetzt und
wirklich ein erschöpftes und eigentlich
aufhören möchte aber es nicht schafft
die höhe ganz kurz zu es kommen
regelmäßig neue berichte auf die zeigen
wie drastisch die situation ist und das
ist natürlich ganz viele emotionen aus
und unter diesem umstand fühle ich mich
verpflichtet irgendwie alles zu geben
was ich geben kann um eben dazu
beizutragen dass das schlimmste
vielleicht doch noch abgewendet werden
kann letzten sommer und herbst habe ich
vollzeit aktivismus gemacht das heißt
ich bin morgens aufgestanden und habe
begonnen mich an den laptop zu setzen
und arbeiten zu erledigen
mit einem sitzungen gefahren und habe an
aktionen teilgenommen jetzt im moment
ist es etwas weniger aber es sind immer
noch so mindestens zehn stunden pro
woche was man auch bedenken muss ist
dass nicht nur die zeit die man am sitz
und verbringt aktivismus ist sondern
auch das beständige oder die beständige
gedankliche auseinandersetzung mit der
klimakrise die auch dazu kommt und die
bei sehr vielen aktivistinnen einen
großen teil des lebens einnimmt ich
finde mich extrem allein gelassen es
heißt immer dass so dass studienalltag
dass die beste zeit des lebens sei man
sei da noch nicht gebunden und habe zeit
um sich selbst kennenzulernen und hat
man habe zeit um zu reisen und ein
tolles sozialleben zu haben aber wenn
man mal begriffen hat wie schlimm die
ganze situation eigentlich ist und nicht
einfach die augen zuhalten möchte ist
man die ganze zeit in dieser
auseinandersetzung mit der eigenen zu
zukunft aber auch mit der gegenwart
jetzt an alle oder es fragen uns alle wo
ist denn die euphorie geblieben im 2009
10 hatte aber was für eine euphorie ist
noch zu erwarten wenn man seine halbe
jugend in aktivismus steckt und damit
doch nichts erreicht aktivismus muss
nicht spaß machen aktivismus ist
notwendig wir machen das nicht
freiwillig
die wochen das nicht freiwillig machen
möchte der jungen frau vielleicht
trotzdem sagen entspannt ich mal ein
bisschen aber sie wehrt sich dagegen
also ich möchte schon sagen ja
vielleicht ist das schon der punkt in
dieser seine wo wir aufgetreten sind
haben viel darüber geredet ist wichtig
dass wir uns engagieren für andere aber
es ist glaube ich schon auch wichtig
dass wir uns selber auch sorge tragen
und dabei nicht ausbrennen unter anderem
schon innerhalb der logik des aktivismus
weil ich natürlich auch die umso bessere
hat gewiss den bender umso bessere
mitmensch wenn es mir gut geht wenn
hierfür die kraft habe aber auch
natürlich für also ganz fundamental weil
ich selber auch zu denjenigen menschen
gehöre die einen anspruch auf ein
glückliches leben haben und die not von
anderen glaube ich verpflichtet mich
selten dazu mich ins unglück zu stürzen
was kann man tun sie hat ja auch gesagt
sie sie fühlt sich alleine gelassen und
dass das ist sehr interessant ich glaube
etwas was auf jeden fall hilft es
sich in der gemeinschaft zu empfinden
und an der stelle ist es eben auch eine
verantwortung
dieser bewegungen auf ihre aktivistinnen
sorge zu tragen das ist glaube ich auch
etwas was sehr sehr ernst genommen werde
zum beispiel in verschiedenen der
klimabewegung station rebellion oder so
daneben nehmen diese verantwortung sehr
ernst versuchen die soziale utopie für
für die sie kämpfen in der ferne auch in
der eigenen bewegung schon zu leben
vielleicht noch noch einen punkt weil
sie gesagt hat
wo ist die euphorie geblieben ich glaube
und das das hat man auch sehr stark
gehört ein grund für dieses für das
ausbrennen und und erschöpfen kann ja
diese verzweiflung sein ich bemühe mich
und bemühe mich aber ich verändere
nichts und ich kann das nachvollziehen
sehr stark nachvollziehen dieses gefühl
ich glaube es kann da manchmal helfen
den eigenen horizont ein bisschen zu
verschieden und zwar in zweierlei
hinsicht erst mal sozusagen zu
verkleinern klar ich kann als
einzelpersonen nicht die klimakrise
aufhalten aber ich kann doch etwas
bewirken also wir haben alle zb die
möglichkeit menschenleben zu retten und
das hilft zwar noch nicht oder beseitigt
die große krise aber es doch auch
einfach bewundernswert und bemerkenswert
und da sollten wir mal feiern und ich
glaube andererseits sollten wir dann
auch manchmal den den blick erweitern
den horizont erweitern und die
längerfristige perspektive im blick
nehmen wenn wir uns anschauen was wir in
den letzten 50 jahren zum beispiel in
hinsicht auf sexismus oder rassismus
oder speziesismus also diskriminierung
von mitgliedern anderer spezies tieren
erreicht haben dann ist es fantastisch
und auch das sollten wir erst mal feiern
und ich glaube das kann dann
grund geben nicht nur für verzweiflung
sondern auch für hoffnung dass wir eben
doch vielleicht etwas erreichen kann
längerfristig betrachtet hat sich an
diesem diskurs sehr schwierig wenn wir 3
erzielen ist weil das dass wir sagen ja
entspannt ich mal und damit letztendlich
sie wieder verantwortlich waren für das
genau dass sie hat eigentlich heißt er
sehr schnell jeder ist seines glückes
schmied
aber die wahrheit ist auch die jedes
medien hat glück
das hängt auch ganz viel davon ab wie es
das umfeld der dieser menschen die unter
burnout leiden oder burn out bekommen
und entwickeln diese dieses gefühl der
selbstwirksamkeit
das gefühl nichts zu bewirken das ist
teilweise auch gewollt also ich erlebe
das als aktivist für inklusion in
deutschland wie oft wir eingeladen
werden von politiker innen zur anhörung
dass wir irgendwo uns beteiligen dürfe
nicht in welchen beteiligungs prozessen
innerhalb von 48 stunden 300 seiten
feinste juristischen literatur lesen
dürfen vorab bevor das irgendwie im
bundestag diskutiert wird und dann
ehrenamtlich unsere juristische
expertise abgeben müssen und niemand uns
dafür bezahlt und wir aber gleichzeitig
uns mit staatssekretären und leuten
dafür bezahlt werden dann eine minute
zeit bekommen um dann mit unserem punkt
zu machen und du weißt genau in diesen
48 stunden diese literatur liest nobody
cars für beide eine minute
wir sind so dass man wahrscheinlich die
sogenannte klima jugend gerne mal
einlädt die lieferung ist und sie sagt
ja auch es sind einfach zu wenige leute
die diese arbeit übernehmen die bewegung
ist kleiner geworden
nun könnte man natürlich um vielleicht
doch einmal die gegenseite doch stark zu
machen es gibt ja im anschluss an
jean-paul sartre auch dieser vorwurf
dass man sagt man ja die jugend ist
immer das alter des ressentiments das
hat schon brachte so gesagt es gehört
zur jugend dazu dass wir nicht
begeistert sind von dem was der rest der
welt veranstaltet fall nicht die ältere
generation wir wollen uns engagieren
dagegen was hat sich denn verändert und
was sie wahrscheinlich sagen würde na ja
die dringlichkeit hier verändert sich
die welt in einer art und weise da geht
es nicht einfach um ein privat
ressentiment sondern da geht es um die
ganz große sache endlich ob wir
überleben werden und ich glaube auch ich
habe vorhin gesagt es ist sozusagen in
der verantwortung innerhalb einer
bewegung auf ihre aktivistinnen sorgen
zu tragen letztlich glaube ich aber es
ist natürlich eben die verantwortung von
von der menschheit insgesamt weil die
probleme sind ja eben nur so groß weil
es eben so wenige leute sind die sich
wirklich dagegen engagieren und wir
können aktives bern hat auch dann
verhindern wenn eben der rest der
menschheit endlich auch mehr in bewegung
in bewegung käme
hier von der jugend schon nicht mehr
engagieren also ich meine ja krauthausen
macht er schon sehr viel wir bei
bekannten ja auch beitreten der
klimabewegung sehr viel mehr machen also
wo ist unsere noch immer wo ist
eigentlich unsere pflicht wie weit
gediegen
natürlich eine schwierige frage ich will
auch gar nicht so sehr von dieser
pflicht dementsprechend diese ideal hier
lastet die moral auf meiner schulter und
sind doch moral ist genau das ist das
risiko eben das moralphilosophen dass
man immer moralisieren nur von der
pflicht spricht ich will schon auch
betonen es kann wir uns auch selber
bereichern uns uns zu engagieren ich
muss nicht und ich glaube auch das ist
sozusagen psychologisch manchmal
effizienter dass ich nicht eben lieber
über meinem schuldgefühl in das
engagement finden sondern eben zum
beispiel über eine vorstellung von
sinnhaftigkeit also ich glaube zum
beispiel ob unser leben letztlich ein
gelungenes leben war hängt auch damit
zusammen ob es sinnvoll war und sinn
ergibt sich oft dadurch dass ich mich
einer sache wird mir die größer ist als
ich selber so einem werte hinaus reicht
über den wert meines eigenen wohls also
wenn ich nur mein eigenes wohl als
wertvoll empfinde in jeder handlung mein
eigenes wohl im blick habe ich gefahr
ein sinnentleertes leben zu leben ich
glaube also insofern haben wir
persönlich durch engagement auch viel zu
gewinnen letzten vielleicht nichts
geringeres als den sinn unseres lebens
das ist ja auch so wenn wir die leute
fragen was war der sinn ihres lebens
werden sie nicht sagen dass ich jeweils
am feierabend mein glas rotwein trinken
konnte sondern sie werden sagen ja dass
ich meinen kindern gutes leben
ermöglichen konnte was ich mich für
meine patienten eingesetzt hat oder eben
dass ich ein bisschen was dazu
beigetragen haben die klimakrise
abzuwenden wann sie steckte das hier
auch darüber gehen bekennen was würde
ihr helfen
also ich meine umarmung etwa ganz
einfach platt gesagt oder eben auch
etwas auf wir kochen jetzt mal was ich
gott was jetzt kann auch schon helfen
dass man überhaupt gesehen und auch
gewerkt wird aber was aktivisten denn
wie wie sie ja permanent erleben ist das
dafür dass sie sich einsetzen auch in
der öffentlichkeit bestraft werden wenn
sie werden doch mal aus versehen mit dem
starbucks becher erwischt werden ja und
dann letztlich auch noch die die moral
in schwerin schwer werden aktivistinnen
lastet danach werde ich immer alles
richtig zu machen und dann letztendlich
in diese freiheiten noch mehr genommen
wird sich auch mal von netflix zu
entspannen und das ist ein großes
problem es gibt die initiative in
deutschland die nennt sich zähneputzen
und das ist im prinzip einfach so man
man biete jemanden einen raum wo völker
wartungsfrei und bedingungslos die
person sich erst mal die zähne putzen
kann entspannen kann ein mann 34 tage
selber wieder die person ist die man vor
dem aktivismus war um überhaupt erst mal
wieder zu kräften zu kommen und diesen
raum zur verfügung zu stellen kann auch
schon aktivistisch sein und engagement
seien
man muss nicht gleich vorne mit einem
transparent auf der demo stehen sondern
man kann auch den aktivistinnen dabei
helfen ihre arbeit weiterhin zu tun das
war sozusagen der versuch noch einmal zu
klären was können wir tun für aktivisten
aktivisten die sehr müde und erschöpft
sind sie hatten vorhin ja noch erwähnt
wir sollten gar nicht dass er darüber
sprechen haben jetzt nicht pflicht
sondern es ist einfach das schönere
besseren war eine sinnvollere leben wenn
wir uns für dinge engagieren und zwar
für die richtigen dinge also nicht für
irgendwas sondern eben für dinge die
sozusagen den respekt untereinander
vergrößern genau darf ich noch einen
anderen gedanken einfügen denn ich
persönlich enorm inspirieren finde und
der so alt ist eigentlich wie die
westliche philosophie
aristoteles hat gemeint das wohl des
menschen besteht darin dass wir unsere
natürlichen anlagen zur entfaltung
bringen also man kann das vergleichen
mit dem wohl eine pflanze eine eiche zum
beispiel jedes gut wenn sie eben gemäß
ihrer natürlichen anlagen gedeihen kann
also wurzeln schlägt wächst blüten trägt
und genauso meint ernst wurde das geht
es den menschen gut wenn er gedeiht also
psychisch und körperlich
gesund und aktiv ist und untersuchen und
hafte leben und hafte leben genau da der
entscheidende punkt für uns tut es ist
jetzt dass der mensch seiner natur nach
immer schon einen sohn politikern ist
das heißt ein soziales ein
gesellschaftliches wesen mit anderen
worten wir finden eben zu der
vollkommenen menschlichen entfaltung nur
in einem funktionierenden gemeinwesen
und in unserem beitrag zu diesen
gemeinwesen also man könnte gerade zu
sagen der mensch ist nur da ganz mensch
wenn er sich engagiert also dieser
gedanke das ist es auch was
bedauerliches wenn ich eben nur auf mein
eigenes wohl gedacht bin ein sehr
schöner gedanke und erleidet uns doch
über zur frage warum denn nicht in die
politik gehen und das ist auch ein
kapitel in ihrem buch weil viele würden
natürlich sagen ja aktivismus in ehren
aber trete doch in eine partei ein weil
es gehört natürlich zum gemeinwesen auch
dazu dass es diese ganz mühsamen
langjährigen prozesse gibt dass man
aushandeln muss kompromiss weich sein
muss da reicht es nicht ich sage jetzt
mag ich die gegner im formulieren würde
da reicht es nicht einfach auf dem
bundesplatz zu setzen sich da fest zu
ketten und blut auszugießen um zu zeigen
wir sterben alle sondern da muss man
sich wirklich auf die klein-klein
paragrafen arbeit einlassen und das ist
eigentlich der beitrag das ist der satz
den der aktivisten ständig hören und
eines ist so eine art täter opfer umkehr
weil die menschen die das sagen sind ja
die gegen das mandat haben dinge
wirklich zu verändern also in
deutschland wäre das der cdu
vorsitzenden friedrich merz der solche
sätze permanent so luisa neubauer den
klimaaktivisten gesagt hat oder unsere
aktuelle finanzminister christian
lindner der ohne vips jetzt zu frei der
s p future gesagt hat ja diese ganze
klima sagt sollte man den experten
überlassen und was entgegnet sich und
dann und anhand dieser bewegung 200
expertinnen in deutschland gefunden die
das bestätigt haben und das heißt was
hier passiert ist nicht der täter opfer
umkehr und die aktivistinnen die wir
gesprochen haben ja alle mit dieser
frage hat also das ist ja auch eine
typfrage bin ist jemand der sich mit
diesen ganzen gesetzes dingen
auseinandersetzen möchte der daran
freude hat sich auch bei kampf zu widmen
und so weiter und so fort oder bin ich
jemand der eher
kreative aktion sich über die
personalpolitik gar nicht so einfach
nicht und das ist den individuelle frage
wir haben aktivisten gesprochen die
sowohl jetzt gerade in die politik
gegangen sind als auch die als experte
den in der politik eigene organisation
gegründet haben um den gleichen mist
stand zu bekämpfen wie zb gerhard schick
der die finanz wende gegründet hat und
vorher finanzpolitischer experte bei den
grünen das scheint mir schon wichtig
dass es hier nicht darum geht das eine
gegen das andere auszuspielen also
selbstverständlich braucht es beides
braucht unbedingt natürlich auch die die
leute in den politischen institutionen
die sich einst absolut für diese
anliegen und das sei aber wohl auch weil
diese menschen dann eben institutionell
eingebunden sind auch die arbeit draußen
auf der straße also ging's anliegen den
zwei arbeitern man muss aber obwohl ich
gegen was zu verändern ist vielleicht
sogar nachhaltiger also wenn ich das
geschafft habe dafür zu sorgen dass
behinderte menschen vom wahlrecht
ausgeschlossen werden da bleibt das ja
so erstmal genau man muss natürlich auch
noch sagen man muss überhaupt die
möglichkeit haben sich beteiligen zu
dürfen weil viele die sich in der klima
jugend engagieren haben nicht das
stimmrechtsalter erreicht das heißt sie
können noch gar nicht im engeren sinne
in die politik gehen oder denken wir an
die bürgerrechtsbewegung in den usa die
damals natürlich losgegangen ist
ausgehend von afro-amerikanern
afroamerikaner die schlicht nichts zu
sagen hatten ich würde gern noch einen
schritt weiter gehen mit ihnen und
darüber sprechen dass sich der ganze
aktivismus ja massiv verändert hat mit
den sozialen medien aber da ist noch
einmal etwas ganz anderes eigentlich
passiert und da sind sie ja auch ein
beispiel herr krauthausen sie sind sehr
aktiv in den sozialen medien und machen
darin mit großer selbstironie und viel
witz aufmerksam auf anliegen hier sehen
wir beispielsweise ein bild von
instagram wo sie sagen so sieht
diversität aus oder wir sehen sie hier
in einem kühlschrank sitzen wenn es sehr
heiß wird dreams come true da haben sich
ja witzig dazugeschrieben eigentlich
würden wir doch insgeheim allemal davon
träumen in einem kühlschrank zu sitzen
wenn es dann wirklich so heiß wird und
es gibt auch einen tick tock video von
ihnen wo sie erklären warum die rede von
menschen mit besonderen bedürfnissen
nicht besonders hilfreich ist ja gucken
uns das ganz kurz an meiner straßberger
auch menschen mit behinderung ich sag ja
immer menschen mit besonderen
bedürfnissen mensch mit behinderung
haben keine besonderen bedürfnisse
haben wir doch alle ja klar aber aber
sie sind eben besonders jetzt zeigt so
speziell ja aber das ist eine klassische
verschönerung ein euphemismus
also ich meine da wird etwas
schöngeredet aber nicht wirklich schöner
gemacht aber wo liegt denn da das
problem wenn man etwas schöner redet was
das problem ist dass du die bezeichnung
der betroffenen einfach übergeht und
ignoriert und das ist ignorant
eine freundin von mir
eher krauthausen sie erreichen mit
diesen videos extrem viele menschen ist
es auch ein ort wo sie hingegangen sind
weil sie sagen das ist eigentlich der
eigentlich inklusive ort überhaupt da
kann wirklich jeder mitmachen also das
könnte jetzt so behaupten aber das
stimmt natürlich nicht also mit der egal
welche technologie wir beschreiben sie
ist immer erst mal werd neutrales gibt
technologien die können genauso wieder
ausschließen wie sie eben auch
vielleicht barrieren beseitigen können
wenn die videos keine untertitel der
abtreten oder audi diskretion was dieses
video nicht hatte dann schließe ich
letztendlich für sehbehinderte menschen
aus über behinderte menschen haben sie
sonst in dialog gar nicht verfolgen
können
das heißt dass erstmal frage ich bin mit
dem internet letztendlich in berührung
gekommen aus beruflicher sicht ich habe
studiert
kommunikationswissenschaften und bin
dann später in online agenturen
gelandeter werbekampagnen mit geplant
war dann beim radio und da war das
internet mein werkzeug und ich habe dann
irgendwann verstanden ok es macht einen
unterschied ob ich einfach ein auto
bewerber oder ein thema und meine
ursprungsidee war ich möchte den
follower innen eine minute am tag den
einblick in das leben eines behinderten
menschen geben und die können dann
machen was sie wollen damit aber ein
fachmann die perspektivwechsel wagen und
aus ihrer 1 minute führt jetzt und
zwischen den ersten stunde an den ich
mich damit aktiv auseinandersetzen und
man kann ja sagen strengt das ist
anstrengend das ist arbeit das ist
völlig klar dass kommt so locker her
aber dass ich sehr viel arbeit solche
videos zu machen aber im grunde genommen
kann man ja sagen das ist schon ein raum
die sozialen medien die noch einmal sehr
viel mehr menschen eigentlich ermöglicht
haben sich zu beteiligen wenn man sich
auch überlegt menschen im süden die
plötzlich die möglichkeit haben sich zu
äußern gesehen werden möglicherweise
andererseits ist sind die sozialen
medien auch ein raum für viele haus und
für viele hätten aber ich glaube schon
also erstmal aus aktivistischer sich das
schon dass das potenzial besonders
interessant also die drei vielleicht
größten heutigen sozialen bewegungen
sind wohlfeil ist für future blood sweat
& me to und diese begriffe also freiheit
für viele plakate und me to waren
ursprünglich alles herstellt also das
sind ganz wörtlich bewegungen die aus
den sozialen medien entstanden sind und
es ist auch nicht erst heute soweit man
hat schon vor zehn jahren im arabischen
frühling gehört diese revolution
ganz wesentlich über den sozialen medien
orchestriert wurden also das ist auf
jeden fall ich würde auch gar nicht die
hast debatte endlich etwas genauso
aufhängen so hoch aufhängen wie das was
das internet auch an möglichkeiten
bietet das ist nicht gleichwertig es
existiert es existierte vorher aber auch
der macht sie jetzt gleich mit größere
bahn und betrifft auch viele menschen
das ist alles ganz schrecklich aber es
ist nicht genau so schrecklich wie das
internet die bewegung auch gefördert und
befeuern kann das besondere am internet
würde ich sagen mit den finanzen
heisterkamp rennen ist dass wir es
schaffen
an chefredaktionen vorbei die bisher
meistens männer waren an chefredaktionen
vorbei eigene dringlichkeiten nach oben
zu bringen also zum beispiel black
selbstmörder oder mieter sind alles
themen die weiße cis männer nicht
betroffen haben
da jetzt eine eigene aufmerksamkeit zu
erzeugen und und reichweiten die dann
die medien dazu zwingen sich das auf zu
äußern und zu positionieren wenn auch
was dazu zu machen bei im internet das
abgeht und das
die neue chefredaktion ist er vielleicht
der algorithmus der jetzt von instagram
und facebook und dicker entscheidet was
wichtig ist und was nicht damit müssen
wir auch auseinander setzen kritisch
aber es ist letztendlich die gelegenheit
minderheiten eine möglichkeit zu geben
überhaupt erstmal sichtbarkeit zu
bekommen die vorher nie stadt kommt die
themen sind aber die gleichen aber ist
eine schwierigkeit nicht auch dieses
eben so genannten herr stark aktivismus
wie man was ja auch nennt das mir in
diesen aktivisten verfallen
zusammengesetzt aus lack faulenzen auf
englisch und aktivismus also gemütlich
auf dem sofa rumlungern und dann ein
schwarzes quadrat posten
blatter
mäßig quasi nach diesem gewaltsamen tod
von george wright oder im moment ist
gerade breit monat also dann irgendwie
die die regenbogenflagge zu posten bis
hin zu unternehmen die im moment ihre
ganzen versagen mit der regenbogenflagge
dekorieren ist das wirklich im sinne
dieser bewegung ist es nicht in den
defekt muss man sagen vielleicht einfach
unnütz vielleicht auch sogar schädlich
also erstmal ist es gut wenn man sich
bekennt zu einem moralisch wichtigen
anliegen ich glaube schon problematisch
wird es dann wenn man das gefühl hat
damit hat man hinreichend viel getan und
man muss mehr auch nicht tun also zum
beispiel die regenbogenflagge raus zu
hängen oder
irgendwas zu posten
kann dann genau uns uns daran hindern
mehr zu tun
insbesondere weil dieses
engagement auf den sozialen manchmal
eben dann wenn es nur darin besteht dass
die posten gar nicht so viel bringt es
kann wie sie gesagt haben sogar schaden
eben weil man manchmal diese anliegen
auch trivialisiert also man suggeriert
eben der rassismus ist nicht so schlimm
ist genügt eigentlich wenn ich hier
einmal ein schwarzes quadrat poster oder
man suggeriert
das massaker das jüngste massaker in der
ukraine war gar nicht so schlimm ich
kann am morgen ein bild von meinen
nackten oberkörper aus dem gym posten
und abends ein bild von meinem
abendessen dazwischen ein massaker in
der ukraine kommentieren mit einem
blauen und gelben herzchen das ist dann
eine eine form der trivialisierung
gleichzeitigkeit sehen sie problematisch
einerseits diese gleichzeitigkeit wie es
dann erscheinen sozusagen aber eben ein
allgemeiner vielleicht ist es eine
fahrende trivialisierung wenn man zu
gerät ist es damit genügend getan indem
man sich auf diese weise äußert ich
würde allerdings vielleicht auch sagen
eben problematisch an problematischen
ist nicht der individuelle aktivierung
einzelner individuen sondern eben
problematischer wird es dann wenn
unternehmen das betreiben oder wenn
kommission dass sie vielleicht gar nicht
ob das heuchlerisch ist mag ich jetzt
mal ganz böse also ob ich das nur pro
wusste um ihr selber einen noblen am
strich zu gehen stichwort moral grenzt
an den wie das us-team 1000 brandenburg
in ihrem buch
oder ist es wirklich ausdruck eines
engagements kann ja auch jemand der
wirklich arktis oder aktivistin ist
einer der alles stellvertreter debatte
wer führen werden wir darüber
diskutieren ob das jetzt die ware
aktivismus ist oder nicht diskreditieren
wir die ganze zeit aktivismus als
solchen weil irgendwie ja wir machen
doch beweist doch erst mal dass du
wirklich gut genug bist und es gibt
menschen die posten blaue und gelbe
herzen und das ist für sie aktivismus
und das würde ich jetzt erstmal ab
könnte jetzt auch noch nicht wirklich
aktivistisch aber für die person dafür
jetzt nicht kritisieren wenn netflix das
tut ohne dann irgendwie was für die
ukraine zu tun und kritischen
schauspieler in den verkauf zu fördern
zu unterstützen im land oder orden im
ausland dann will ich das schon
fragwürdig weil netflix originäres
business ist eigentlich filme machen
oder was aber schwierig sie richtiger
krauth sie haben im grunde genommen es
ist ein stellvertreter der partie man
sagt sehr gerne ja ja herr stark
aktivisten wie lächerlich und möchte
damit im grunde genommen ablenken
2000 auseinandersetzen müssen und
moralisch selbst irgendwie positionieren
müssen was er engagiere ich mich
eigentlich stattdessen diskreditiere ich
andere und er macht mich dadurch
vielleicht auch moralisch höher und das
funktioniert online super und ich glaube
dass wir
vielleicht auf die frage stellen ob
james juni das ist der plot man was
machen wir denn im oktober zu diesem
thema so und derjenige der der gegen
bogen frage im oktober als marke postet
und nicht im juli was alle machen da
würde ich schon eine höhere moralische
verantwortung auch dann erkennen aber
wir machen mir sehr grad nur und die
marken machen das nur stichworte wie der
aufmerksamkeit weil das gerade kohle ist
weil das schickal ist und an gesagt wir
haben jetzt in ganz viel über
ukrainische flüchtlinge gesprochen oder
geflüchtet menschen die schutz suchen
aber wir interessieren uns mit über die
sirenen die genauso zu suchen und das in
deutschland sind menschen aus der
ukraine höhere soziale unterstützung
bekommen vom staat als syrische
flüchtlinge die aber beide flüchtlinge
sind ist eigentlich der wahre skandal
und wir müssten uns einig jetzt
mindestens genauso für syrische
geflüchtete engagieren wenn wir das mit
flüchtlings thematik allgemein wirklich
so ernst nahm und es ist interessant
jetzt gar siege zu gucken wer sitzt in
diesen bereichen eigentlich immer noch
wert sind jetzt wie syrische
geflüchteten wer setzt sich im oktober
für den breitband ein oder für die
bewegung und die zu unterstützen das ist
vielleicht oder das halten und
vielleicht auch wenn sie sagen
nachhaltiger das finde ich doch einmal
zurück was sie gesagt haben mit der
sinnhaftigkeit des engagement
wahrscheinlich kann ja nur wirklich
diese sind dimension im leben geben wenn
seine eben auch ernst ist und dann ist
es nicht so ein so eine mini stimmung
ich poste jetzt hier mal irgendwas
sondern das sickert dann irgendwie durch
unbedingt dass ich glaube wenn ich
sozusagen vielleicht auch erst im
nachhinein erkennen muss dass all meine
äußere aktivismus eigentlich egoistisch
motiviert war und ging nur darum die
eigene fassade zu wahren oder irgendwie
gut dazustehen dann kann auch das mich
in eine sinnkrise stürzen also ich werde
sehen dass ich eben letztlich nicht die
relevante form von respekt gegenüber den
menschen gezeigt habe die idee
eigentlich diesen diesen sinn stiften
würde also ich glaube auch sozusagen
noch mal es ist haben wir auch selber
nur zu gewinnen wenn wir
andere dinge um ihrer selbst willen
wertschätzen und uns ja das gab es die
hat in dem buch auch gesagt dass es
viele aktivisten gibt die das wort
aktivismus für sich zeitig gebrauchen
weil sie es nicht okay finden dass
dieser begriff so diskreditiert wird
teilweise von der elite von politiker
innen jeder sagen ja das sind diese
aktivisten und damit aber erkennen dass
die auch expertinnen sind auf trabi
diese menschen das studiert sind
jahrzehnte in diesen bereichen aktiv und
haben viel mehr ahnung als die politiker
innen in diesen bereichen wir müssen
hier leider muss ist nicht das gegenteil
von
profession wir müssen hier leider zu
einem ende kommen mit diesem plädoyer
auch diesen aktivismus wirklich ernst zu
nehmen selbst wenn es vielleicht
dazwischen nur und posten von einem
quadrat ist ganz ganz herzlichen dank
dass sie hier zu gast waren stefan
rehder raul krauthausen vielen dank
herzlichen dank
ja zum weiterlesen verlosen wir dieses
buch hier signiert von raul krauthausen
teilnehmen können sie auf meiner
instagram seite oder auf unserer sendung
seite unter mehr zur sendung wie wir
etwas bewegen das fragt diese woche auch
der kultur platzverbot verzicht
veränderung wie schaffen wir die
klimawende und welche wege wählen junge
menschen die sendung gibt es in unserer
mediathek nächste woche jetzt hier
lustig oder auch nicht ich bossert
spricht mit der kabarettistin lisa
eckhard über die subversive kraft des
lachens und über die moralischen grenzen
des humors und jetzt geht es ebenfalls
um einen der die welt verändern will und
zwar mit den mitteln der kunst vorhang
auf für den regisseur milo rau der mit
seiner neuinterpretation des wilhelm
tell für gesprächsstoff sorgt ihnen
allen eine gute zeit bis bald
[Musik]